oh the Democrats have never Trump
fanatics are going totally off the rails
my friends earlier this week we exposed
their true motives during this partial
government shutdown they want to keep it
going as long as possible for pure
political gain it's as simple as that
the American people and the government
workers be damned it's all about trying
to embarrass the president so much for
governing it's pathetic now tonight we
take it a step further
night after night we're gonna
systematically expose the tactics and
methods that the Democrats and their
media collaborators use to advance their
extreme agenda now I call this edition
the cruel hoax President Trump has
hurled coarse insults at everybody from
senators to stormy Daniels he has
separated immigrant children from their
parents at the border the pattern here
cruelty I think what Trump practices is
cruelty he his part of his brand is
cruelty the Trump administration adopted
a conscious policy of cruelty this is
what President Trump was he's using
cruelty as his message I'm sorry it's so
preposterous and so obvious they write
entire articles devote entire segments
to making their cruelty case no need to
debate actual issues or propose actual
solutions when it's so much easier just
to call someone a name like racist
sexist misogynist or in this case cruel
check out these ludicrous headlines no
matter what remember if Trump's involved
it must be a cruel outcome like any
issue regarding transgenderism or budget
priorities and one of my personal
favorites the nice elaborate argument
made by former bushy Michael Gerson that
it's not just that Trump's cruel it's
also that he encourages other leaders
around the world to be cruel too and of
course anything related to immigration
short of a wave them all in policy is
always going to be cruel well you get
the point
liberals and never Trump errs want you
to believe that they have the monopoly
on compassion and if you don't
believe in their social and economic and
foreign policy agenda you're not just
wrong you're cruel and Trump's the
cruelest of all it might come down to
the fact that he could well be just an
empty man and a human being with no soul
so trying to get over
Michael Steele's red sweater situation
that's cruel now my friends the Buddha
said is paraphrasing that the finger is
always pointed back you so watch what
you're doing with the cruel language
just look at the current border standoff
issue and it's apparent that the
Democrats and the never Trump purse are
actually the cruelest of them all while
they spent months on the border by
moaning the plight of migrant families
in detention centers they treat American
victims of illegal alien crime with
complete indifference and even scorn
after the president said this in his
oval office address over the last
several years I've met with dozens of
families whose loved ones were stolen by
illegal immigration I will never forget
the pain in their eyes the tremble and
their voices and the sadness gripping
their souls how much more American blood
must we shed before Congress does its
job unfunny
NBC's late-night host Seth Meyers
responded this way on Twitter is this
Oval Office SVU gosh mocking the plight
of victims as if they're just collateral
damage in the battle for open borders
and for Democrats like Pelosi and others
it's always something like sure any life
lost is tragic but being concerned about
every death that happens because of
because we live in an imperfect world
and that's very sad listen terrible
stories and we don't want to minimize
the pain of any victims any family that
anyone is feeling right but it's awful
these tragedies
shouldn't happen but president trunk
backing up is dire warnings with grizzly
stories of crimes blamed on undocumented
immigrants but okay that could be my
favorite new graphic but there is no but
these are Americans who would be alive
today if politicians did their jobs and
did everything that was necessary to
protect America's borders now we're
constantly lectured about being
sensitive to victims and hearing them
out and that's fair and we all say a lot
we're fish we're on TV and sometimes you
overstep I get it
no one's perfect but we have to find
some sensitivity here for the victims of
legal immigrant crime are they to be
ignored just because they don't fit a
particular ideology and conservatives
shouldn't do this on what another issue
happens Andra little shouldn't do it
here and when someone does try to
mention the suffering of illegal alien
crime victims sadly they're treated this
way even if I were to grant you that
okay the point is the illegal aliens
crime rate should be zero it should be
you can do your nails you know who can't
do their nails are people who have been
killed Anna by dangerous known illegal
aliens who've been allowed to stay in
this country because of the leftist
policies that people like you promote in
so-called sanctuary cities okay raise
your hand if you think Anna Navarro does
her own nails but look Republican
Impostors like Navarro are cruelly
indifferent that was a cute little stunt
in the double boxes but their
callousness extends not only to
Americans who paid them about a hundred
fifty billion dollars a year tab that
illegal immigration cost to us but also
the indifference to those Americans in
legal immigrants who've been raped
abused trafficked run over and murdered
sadly by certain vicious illegal aliens
when California officer ronnie'll Singh
was laid to rest last week after being
killed by an illegal during a routine
traffic stop California Governor Gavin
Newsom attended an NBA game
senator Kamala Harris did offer her
respects however to the rapper come
somehow she found the time to hang out
there no attending the funeral of an
outstanding constituent and these are
the people who have the nerve to call
Donald Trump cruel if it's not a death
that they can exploit for political gain
they're just not interested in it at all
meanwhile Trump is truly concerned about
the children on both sides of the border
and the only way to protect them is to D
incentivize the dangerous trip northward
and to build the wall to reinforce an
orderly immigration process to let the
current situation persist would be truly
cruel and that's the angle